هذه حرب بطائرات بدون طيار لأن روسيا
تريدك أن تراها
قوات موسكو تلاحق
المدافعين الأوكرانيين في بلدة بوبوزنا بدعم
من المراقبة من السماء ،
وجلست مع خبير عسكري
لتحليل 22 دقيقة من اللقطات الجوية
التي نشرتها قنوات الكرملين الموالية ،
فماذا؟  أنا أنظر هنا إلى هذا
العمود ، لذا فهم جنود روس هناك
حوالي ثمانية جنود ، انتقل الجنود الأوائل
إلى الخندق لنوع ما
يسمونه واضحًا هذا الخندق ونرى
أن الجندي الأوكراني يخرج من
هذا السقيفة مرارًا وتكرارًا.  نحن
هناك ، إنه نعم ، لكن هناك نيران أسلحة صغيرة
تحدث الآن ،
وسيتحدث كل من كان على متن الطائرة بدون طيار
إلى هؤلاء الجنود على أساس أن هذا
قريب من القتال المكثف مع
رؤية محدودة يعتمد عليها المقاتلون الروس هنا
على مشغل الطائرة بدون طيار للحصول على
نظرة عامة وذكاء في الوقت الفعلي ،
نحن على وشك رؤيته
ينشر قنبلة أخرى هذه المرة
سيحصل على القليل  عن قرب وقد فعل ذلك
بشكل صحيح هذه المرة إذا لم تقتله تلك القنبلة اليدوية ،
فسأكون مندهشًا بشكل خاص
إذا نجا
الآن شاهد هذا الجزء بعناية ،
وما زلنا نبحث في نفس الموقع
ولكن الآن هناك ستة رجال على الأقل تم القبض عليهم
على الأرض يُزعم أن
المدافعين الأوكرانيين الآن يمكننا أن نرى الجنود الروس
الذين تم وضع علامة
عليها بشارات بيضاء وشرائط الساق
البيضاء ولدينا سلسلة من الجنود الذين
يبدو أنهم سجناء على
الأرض ولا نعرف أين هؤلاء
الجنود  لقد جاءوا من الخطة
هنا بمجرد أن يحصلوا على هؤلاء الرجال ،
قيل لهم أن يخلعوا الدروع الواقية من أجسامهم
حتى يتم تجريدهم من
نوع قدرتهم القتالية
فورًا لدينا هنا
جندي روسي يبدو
وكأنه  إعطاء الإيذاء الجسدي
لأسير حرب موجود على
الأرض بعيدًا عن الأنظار ، فهم يبحثون عن
أفراد مهمين يبحثون
عن أفراد ذوي اهتمام استخباراتي
وسيحصلون على  كن بعيدًا عن الاستجواب التكتيكي ،
انظر إلى أن الجندي يركل
ذلك الرجل ، نعم هذا طبيعي تمامًا ولكن
من المثير للاهتمام إلى أين سيذهبون
بعد ذلك ، حيث سيتم الزحف إليهم في قلم حرب الأسرى
وداخل قلم أسير الحرب هذا ،
سيتم البحث عنهم بمزيد من التفاصيل
سيتم استجوابهم
وبعد ذلك سيتم نقلهم إلى
نظام سجن مركزي بشكل أساسي ، حيث
ساعد الاستخدام الفعال للجيش الأوكراني للطائرات بدون طيار التركية الصنع في هزيمة
القوات الروسية حول كييف في
مناطق أخرى الآن يريد الكرملين من العالم أن
يعتقد أنه قادر على ذلك.  نفس النجاح
الذي نشهده هو أن
الروس أبطأ كثيرًا في
التقاط استخدام الطائرات بدون طيار التكتيكية
مقارنة بالأوكرانيين ، لذا هل
تقول الرسالة هنا هي أن ننظر إلى أننا جيدون حقًا
في استخدام الطائرات بدون طيار أيضًا ،
وأعتقد أن الأمر كذلك  لدينا هنا أيضًا
مادة دعائية تعرف
أنها مادة دعائية تم تنظيمها بشكل فعال ، وليس من الواضح متى تم تصوير هذه اللقطات
ولكن القوات الروسية
تسيطر الآن إلى حد كبير على  ما تبقى من
باباسنا وهذا هو تكتيك الكرملين الآخر
المعروض هنا
الأرض المحروقة على الجناح الشرقي
لقد وقفت القوات الأوكرانية إلى حد كبير
على أرضها تتراجع إذا أمكن
الاستسلام عندما لا توجد خيارات متبقية
لبعض هؤلاء cnn london